go welcome to this video from game eight
of the World Championship match in
chennai india between challenge magnus
carlsen and the defending champion vishy
anand and i'll start this video a bit
different than usual because i'm going
to tell you what it looks like here at
my office basically my home office Wham
have a nice window where i can watch an
old lady passing by with the dog their
cup of cars outside some trees leaves
slowly falling down sounds really boring
right well to be honest the game dave
was even more boring this was the
highlight of the video me telling you
what i'm seeing out of my window and but
let's start and probably the time that
this video has only a couple of minutes
gives it away we have are not playing
black keys down by two points and place
the balloon defense which is a bit of a
be a choice if you are two points down I
know it's difficult with black and all
but yeah not so many games left to my
own game aight here so after that game
only four games left and this included
is five-game so how I going to win a
game if you play this kind of opening
well cousin played castles not III and
very pragmatic after Knight takes e4 I
played rookie one and this is one of
those lines where item can really get a
position that is so simplified and easy
to play that it's really take some some
some drastic errors to lose the game
we'll see what happens 96 and i take c 5
this is one of those lines that
community can be recommended for what if
you want to play without any kind of
risk and you have excellent drawing
chances against basically any opponent
yeah black Bishop e7
Bishop have one back it was a tekton be
five of course and now after the trade
castles here white can try a bit more
interesting to play with Knight c3 but
he has a very solid set up deform and c3
and we see that the e file is opened and
there are some quick trades on the file
now 98 freeing up d 5 so that you can
actually develop the bishop and we see
that this happens d 5 g6 gap very
typical maneuver trying to exchange the
bishop and this is hard to prevent the
right bitzer its plate and all this was
played almost instantly by Magnus he
only spent a couple of minutes on those
moves and while he's two points that
he's not the one to to play for any
risks here Anna needs to win two games
and this is the absolutely most
unsuitable opening to win a sub like so
they traded a couple of more pieces and
he a rookie aid of course the rook needs
to go to the e-file and yeah damn that
can that can be moderate snow no problem
Knight g4 and 25 here and now a big
threat basically the only one in the
game 90 f6 check yeah and black needs to
of course take care of that and yeah why
took here to simplify 2 a.k.a porn and
game note that Knight f6 is a way to
even loose after Queen takes f6 there's
a mate only one checkmate okay but what
can just take here it's like slow phase
of fireworks and after that we have
absolutely all pieces traded they are
not allowed to draw before 30 so they
dashed
a couple of mumbles and agreed to draw
here after 33 moves so this is probably
the most boring game I ever covered on a
video and I've done some boring once I
mean remember the last World
Championship match your honor there were
some some bloody dull games but this is
probably the absolute worst possible
okay what what what to say about the
game I don't understand Ananse match
strategy maybe he's just banking on the
fact that he would win one of the next
two games and then Carlton's getting
nervous and he maybe thinks that ok
we'll get into the final game 1 point
down is the dream scenario and then cars
really gets nervous in the face of
wrapping it up I don't know but I think
s black um he should try something I
don't know something more interesting
but I mean in the press conference on
unsaid what am I supposed to do I could
I could play the Sicilian but there are
also some Jewish lines yeah this this is
actually true I mean let's say this he
played the night off very often a heart
but cousin is playing this check they're
probably and he done so before and won
against Ireland and this is also pretty
pretty dry it's it's not easy at all to
play for win against e4 cousins it was
basically a sign to be honest that he is
content with the draw its may be
contrary to the popular and widespread
opinion that if is sharper or anything
it's on the side level the better moved
to make it wrong then deform simply
because many many lines have those kind
of ultra draw variations like the one we
seen before week you can fight in the
Berlin but white always has this exit
option here and simply draw all right I
hope you at least had a little laugh of
out of my intro otherwise this was a
bloody uninteresting
alright we have the rest day tomorrow
and then again a game where Arnold is
white and hopefully this will be the one
way he's trying to actually win a game
and not just just draw thanks for
watching I'll be back in on the thursday
for game 9